Saturated fat caused insulin resistance. Can burberry kill good bacteria?
Burberry can burberry kill good bacteria?
Well, burberry can kill bacteria. Burberry is your treatment of choice, or at least one of the
treatments of choice when you're trying to kill H. Pylori. Burberry is not an antibiotic. So it's not
going to go in there and wipe out your gut flora and destroy all your good bacteria. I wouldn't
be concerned about that whatsoever. So I'd be more concerned that I have an imbalance in my bacteria,
particularly, or at least one, the strong possibility is H. Pylori overgrown to
and that's where burberry will be most beneficial. So I would be concerned about that. As far as
saturated fat causing insulin resistance, I'm sure there's a connection that there could be a
connection. There's been a lot of flaws in the studies of saturated fat, so I don't know if
there are valid studies out there on that. But if a person is having insulin resistant issues and
illnesses that died, there are consuming a lot of saturated fat and something to experiment with.